we've got a voicemail number it is two
one nine two David P I believe we're
hearing from the Eggman today right
let's take a listen to what the Eggman
had to say here hi Dave the Bill Maher
joke was funny you just didn't get it
it wasn't about race it was about class
a house n-word does not work the field
they work inside with the master doing
all the cushy work that's all Bill Maher
was saying and I think a guy that has
lived his whole life fighting for the
rights of African Americans can drop the
n-word in a joke sometimes and it was
funny everything you said was correct
about it except that it wasn't funny
just because you didn't get it doesn't
mean it wasn't funny David that's all
Shalom yeah well uh my sense of humor
aside the Eggman seems to believe that
something was funny and you know what
I've learned pat about whether someone
thinks things are funny or doesn't think
they're funny it's hard to agree about
whether things are funny because it's
subjective and I think on that note I
hate using this term but we're going to
have to agree to disagree don't do it
with the egg man don't do it okay yeah I
don't think it was funny I understood
the joke I just don't think it was funny
on the bonus show today Harvard
withdraws ten acceptances after
offensive memes in online chat the
outcry over EpiPen prices has not
lowered prices at all and more bad news
for United Airlines a United Airlines
supervisor reportedly tried to wrestle
away a violinist from an orchestral
violinist trying to get to a performance
in st. Louis Missouri it's not looking
good lately
for United Airlines all of those stories
and more on the bonus show sign up and
get instant access at david pakman.com
slash membership